2:23 if you want to be an anomaly you
have to act like one hey what somebody
is that well I'll pick a real big one it
came out somewhere to people people
really like it it's true
okay love you
pairings good just sitting in way too
much traffic I don't want to be late for
Johnson Johnson yeah I will I will
Jesus
they don't they don't agencies they lose
their clients to God media companies
have clients and have consumer-facing
brand
what the punchline with this account you
got a note this morning from Gary that
says this scope is being taken over by
me and James if he says what's the deal
with that I think I think documenting
your journey on again medium your own
personal blog YouTube a SoundCloud
anchor you know on and on and on
snapchat on and on and on of you going
through this journey I mean it would be
really cool to have content right now
about when Vera Wang started learning
like literally learning how to how to
create a dress right
too many people either do a what you
think which is first I have to become it
and then I can talk about it and I'll
wait 2 3 4 5 years I think what you need
to do today stat is uh is is find the
way you want to communicate to the world
and and here's the punchline tell the
world the truth good awesome
good luck
it's interesting Dirac finding new ways
to bring value at the daily be mom I
think you should I think I think you
should probably come on and do one show
with me
you're not schmuck across key you can do
it well you should practice with the
rock I'm gonna send D rock once a week
to your house you'll your practice and
then you'll come good boy how are you
things are well put a Sunday night would
you join me for a Knicks game courtside
just spoke to my mom and dad boy are
they different [ __ ] do I love them I
think we should stick it to everybody
that razzed you about the am/pm
and i think we should Easter egg an ampm
switch on every episode
just a stick it it is like comedians or
like musicians like sometimes you want
to play the whole is sometimes you want
to play like the concert you know and
sometimes you want to do the MTV
Unplugged acoustic so yeah you'll play
it it's always predicated on the size of
the room and the amount of people yeah I
tend to stand up at some point when I'm
sitting down
roaaaar you got such a pleasure
how are you welcome good thank you you
are here thank you for having me I'm I'm
stunningly confused by the audacity of
the marketing industry and people to
call me a disruptor when all I want to
do is sell product today and I think
it's time to have real conversations
because this isn't gonna get better
so
thirty years yeah
perfect timing so together I do want to
make sure I get so competitive
is I need to always make sure analogy
because that's when you lose them isn't
it yeah I'm proud that on the actual
practitioner against my own work but you
know dailyvee has been a big win for me
because now people actually can see in
real life that I you are 15 16 hours a
day so but what do I spend that time on
I spend it on five minute meetings with
all my employees 15 minute meetings on
the doing HR with them I'm doing
strategy with them I'm working I'm
working their dinner you know this
garyvee character that lives on social
media that you know does motivational
quotes and rah-rahs rants and does the
show that's me but I'm equally spending
11 12 13 hours of my day being an
executive I'm an actual actual mechanic
I'm inventing the next version of the
screwdriver and then I'm using it I
would say that I'm a believer of passion
but I believe that passion is very
similar and a cousin to happiness and
you need to have it to actually be the
trigger to the tactics that are the
massive rationale to why one is
successful so when you say that when you
say that passion is the ingredient that
most matters in success I agree but
here's how I think about it without
passion nobody if tony hawk's in wasn't
passionate about skateboarding if I
wasn't passionate about becoming one of
the great entrepreneurs of a generation
if LeBron wasn't passionate about
basketball they wouldn't have put in I
wouldn't have put in the hours the work
when you're when it all makes no sense
when it's 10:30 at night tonight and
I've got to go to one more meeting but I
gotta wake up at 5:30
and you know if I'd have the passion for
the game I wouldn't do it
I would cancel it I wouldn't have booked
it in the first place and so it becomes
the gateway drug religion that allows
you to do the tactical things right I
have a vision to where we're going in
the future I come up with stuff every
day that very few people are thinking
about and then in parallel and it's one
of the biggest reasons I still have a
personal brand I use Instagram and
snapchat and Facebook and Twitter every
single day I'm a practitioner I get my
hands dirty I'm the architect and the
Mason literally the architect the
general contractor and the Mason that
was great
wow that was really great that might
have been that could end up being the
best interview I'm gonna give on this
book that hey everybody I don't kind of
talk to you that often on dailyvee but
yeah I don't know how we're gonna edit
that because oh yeah I think you could
probably lead to the questions he asked
you can ask me I don't know if I'll
remember probably not you know how we
roll that felt really good that felt
really really good I want that to be in
the episode end or if you want to take
that out and say why this book as a
separate video that was right I was on
and uh I was able to articulate a lot of
my feelings about this book and that was
excited
d-roc wants me to tell you the favorite
moments from yesterday's thing super 8
first of all thank you guys so much for
being part of it was a lot of fun I
really could see myself doing that once
a week what is this oh my god what is
this I'll tell you what it is it is a
bucket full of receipts I am fired up
right now
bucket full of receipts we're gonna be
pulling look oh look oh my god this
person could you imagine they oh my you
know what I can't do it we're gonna do
something here for this person right now
because it's be unfair this person is
getting ten sign books because that'd be
unfair if like max I don't know what to
do okay fine
ten sign books for this person
congratulations so they bought a they're
getting ten more sign books for me the
winner is you ready you know sometimes
they do things where like I always like
make fun of the fact that my personal
brand isn't my business though it is for
a lot of people which you know kudos
everybody do you don't do me but a day
like yesterday actually makes me think
about how cool it would be if that was
my business because I'm that'd be fun to
do once a week you just would love it so
I don't want to give you my favorite
moments to rock what I want to do is say
that the whole thing is my favorite
moment right like sure there's the part
where I you know singing Miley Cyrus
don't you ever say I just walked away
we'll always want you I came in
sorry sorry sorry I got excited you know
I was that was fun and sure the parts of
like a DJ that was super fun you said L
were you trying out off desk with a
substitute no but that was like I didn't
actually elbow somebody I'm just I I was
telling the class that I love Macho Man
Randy Savage so I stood on the desk jump
in the middle of class and just did the
elbow the flying elbow yeah um when you
have people like al t-shirt I mean
you're just hang out with sharks or
extremely extremely tractive dude I
always say to the poker either sharks or
for people for attractive than me James
the self-deprecation is all times I also
with my bezels alone by the way bands
that's me
bed when drew tonight we should sort of
bed wetters unite you know what I want
it Andrew
Pat hold on one second is important
Andrew I need you to start designing
right away a t-shirt for my tee public
that says bed wetters unite I could
definitely do that thank you
I need an ace app in other marketing
peeps sure I'm a UH where am I looking
at York I mean you would look at this
yeah there's a lot of places to look I'm
a I'm a recovery corporate lawyer turned
ultra endurance athlete written books
finding ultra the plant power way of
sellers I've got a podcast I've been
doing for three years that's super cool
for them getting them exposure in my
community I like giving it at Tibet
people and giving them a chance to meet
different people for you the community
for them
and vice versa is showing up on their
radars and interacting with team getting
the center in room with like India and
Andy and you like you know just Garrett
coming in and like dumping the sheets in
the first time I'm making a joke and oh
okay we'll get it hold on drew I'm sorry
Garrett you screwed up Garrett when we
drop things in the bucket we need to
make a huge deal about it it needs to
inspire the others that are holding out
and breaking my heart don't you ask him
how many cuz I don't even want to know
now Andy you took away my happiness
Garrett and that's it you took my
[ __ ] happiness away or get out of
here let it go
so pissed I'm not I don't suban
don't don't end up in Garret category
okay hold on okay this this is action oh
my god yeah the soda I love this this is
Barrett you redeeming yourself I could
talk about like the different favorite
things that I have happened yesterday
and just know that's I could talk about
that but that's not interesting to me
what's interesting to me is just the
fundamental fact that like a that I'm so
lucky and I know a lot of you say that I
work for and you get mad at me but so
lucky that people care enough to have a
sick day so that a little bit to sit
there watch me for eight hours or that
I'm so lucky that I have a mom and a
sister who watched a lot of it and you
know and called me and showered me with
compliments and things of that nature
that so lucky that I was born with the
energy to be able to do that and then go
out and have four more hours of meetings
those are the things that really strike
me on things like that you know or that
my dad will tell me the next day like
hey should I get should I get a Facebook
cuz he wants to see the nice things I
said about him because my mom probably
told him you know those are the things I
really care about on a day like that hey
brother how are you
good man um I gots to just talk to hey
guns for the first time since the
meeting so sounds like you got a little
context from what happened right
understood running into a meeting I love
your brother talk to you yeah of course
bye-bye
11:14
thank you so much
this new Facebook buttons thing is going
to be super interesting a lot more data
and we're just like a lot of emotions
sad Wow haha you can be angry about my
content it's gonna be a lot more context
which is a super important and will lead
to a a smarter machine which will be
deployed against more opportunities to
story tell so be fun to watch scary for
their telephone Carrie and his security
detail destroido's d-roc is here I do a
daily vlog my whole life is now being
documented the rest of my life don't
worry nothing sensitive you can approve
it
it's b-roll